save Sven I need to save slain how do I
save Sven
how do I do it ah you be quiet
you're disgusting I wish it was you down
there not him god
okay we need dirt we need a lot of dirt
lot of dirt we're gonna build a tunnel I
don't have a lot of dirt god damn it uh
why do I not have dirt we will care we
will dig we will dig I'm gonna need
underwater breathing oh god
Sven is that right now it must be so
scared okay okay okay
I've been meaning to do this for a long
time how do I make an enchantment table
so I can breathe underwater everyone's
been saying it for three years I need
the book and diamond Oh God you know
what it doesn't care I would waste all
my inventory if it means saving Sven
okay we need to do what any second
wasted here it's the second wasted force
when the poor son of a there it is we
have an enchantment table what do I do
with it
I know I'm supposed to place it next to
bookshelves I don't have any bunch else
where do I place it let's put it here
it's pretty good whoa that's cool okay
don't get distracted how does it work
that's the left I don't eat this that
I've been using for freaking die dude
are you kidding me what is this then I
put a book there
projectile protection no I need
underwater breathing sharpness
protection sharpness no give me a
feather falling efficiency smite this is
not helpful okay maybe I have some gear
maybe have some gear in Xiamen
projectile curse of vanishing what is
this we're losing time god damn it look
I have a name tag and I was gonna name
him Beth and I never gave me the same
thing
purchase a flash per ticket right
where's the stupid respiration helmet
we're just gonna dig you're good I need
you we have to save him dig like the
wind Jurgen
shut up shut up I don't care about
filthy TOWIE boobies faster juergen
faster we need dirt lots of dirt do you
think that's dirt that you're digging
right now
Oh zombies is no I'm not going to sleep
I am NOT going Hot Chip I'm big in the
air is there no way you can dig faster
jerking oh my god this is faster without
Jurgen got stopped running a big dig dig
dig dig Oh God
okay I never wanted to do this but I'm
desperate god dammit they could drop a
helmet that I can put on my face and
then I can breathe and well I was so
sorry turtle I'm so oh god it's looking
at me
I can't do it I can't do it Sven
wouldn't have wanted me to kill to save
him big big dick like that how much dirt
do I need this is enough Oh God swam oh
god it's so far away
coming Finn I'm give me to see oh god
it's happening here - what is this
getting sucked dude still sucking almost
ruin my life
can dogs climb ladders can I rope him up
maybe okay here we are gamers okay there
- first let's make sure he's okay good
how did he get here how did this happen
spen today
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry okay don't
worry don't worry we're gonna get you
out of here
oh god okay all right oh god it's
leaking sweat it's leaking so and I'm
panicking okay all right Oh God okay all
right guys stupid gravel I hate you you
ruined my life gravel gotta be careful
if I die Sven dice how how am I gonna do
this
they put a rocket in space goddamn it
you can do this Felix oh god not now
have another Scooby Snack it's not going
great I'm not gonna lie it's not going
great the whole launch event I'm just
gonna go up one second I meant it when I
said it if anything happens to spend
this playthrough over big time
okay okay okay the plane you know what
I'm not even gonna waste time telling
you because I need to get him out god
damn it write like the wind Yoda good
we're coming Fred I don't have a spare
lead for you so we're gonna have to use
the good ol go to a whole technique stay
there I'll be right back
you better be still in there where's
Elon Musk when you need him I needed
submarine where's your submarine II love
but oh god not again I hate this stupid
thing
look the fishes have come to help
they're here for moral support thank you
fish I'm trying my best here okay so the
idea is a little little little crazy
okay all right all right you're okay
you're okay
Oh God oh my god
I'm gonna need you to swim okay all
right all right Plan B here oh it works
here we go here we go stay right behind
me okay this current Oh you can do it
you can do it you can it come in yes yes
we're doing it the fishies are helping
swim swim swim swim swim swim swim sue
sue sue sue sue sue hurry hurry
wait that waiter oh so happy get up on
the platform get up on the platform
there's plenty of space there's plenty
of space get up on the platform I was so
scared sweat get up on the platform
please hello
alright now we got em double safety you
ain't going nowhere
you're I got you now safe and sound hey
oh god oh god
don't go anywhere we're returning home
oh my god I'm so happy oh no no no no no
someone needs to mark that that's
terrible a very no spin it's all over we
did it
minecraft series will continue this
whole show rest on your shoulders
tonight
you can get out of the boat now alright
I'm putting you on a leash come here
you're again you stayed you get look
who's here
I know it's me okay all right gamers
we're heading back home it's getting
dark oh god crap first they loose my
leash again where did I lose it oh Spain
don't hurt my friend get away from Sven
are you just gonna sit there let okay I
get it it's fine you've been busy
ah they got armor Oh God hurry hurry we
got a big a bang ball oh god it's gonna
blow up blow then Oh naughty fredison Oh
God Oh God get eat Penn State 6-6 eight
states eight sing there no no
when I think oh look his tail is down
that means he's hurt
we're gonna have to get Jurgen later oh
wait he eats he eats bones and stuff we
gotta get his health back eat the bone
oh god he doesn't want to eat again
please cooperation I think not
cult okay safe come my child eat
something okay its tail is fine
come here Smith
only I can kill my cows ah then get up
only I can kill my cows hurry up spin
that's it boy good boy good boy good boy
come back I may come in history spin
gent peace I cannot handle this any lug
said please come inside
we got Scooby Snacks we got Scooby
Snacks that's right we got Scooby Snacks
okay sit sit boy there you go
what is happening to you oh I got his
tail I'm going to sleep don't care what
you say I'm going to sleep oh I'm so
stupid
he just hit me about the enchantment I
know Sven I'm an idiot obviously I was
supposed to enchant a helmet to make the
helmet you dumb schmuck
Felix so you just put yes under one
unbreaking aqua infinity there you go
gamers it's as easy as one two three
pee pee poo pee pee if something that we
wanted to do for a long time spent I'm
sorry I didn't do this sooner I lost
oh yeah I got to put the name on the
amulet right Sven my friend you burned
it I wish I did it to an old friend of
mine okay so you guys have been going on
and on and on about how I should put Jeb
underscore on the on the sheep and fine
I guess I'll do it is that even Jeb
underscore wow that's so cool cool now
your name is Jeb did I do it wrong I
think I did it wrong I guess I'll have
to kill you now to get the name tag back
I can't kill Jeb who else will I have to
torture now damn it I have to mention I
have too much stuff I can't be bothered
to clean all this up it's gonna take
ages isn't that right Schmidt it's right
it's right
oh there you are yes I love you too I
love you too man all right
there's a couple things I want to do
today gamer's I need to head back to the
mines because I want to build a tower
like a watchtower so I can find my place
easier does that make sense and now I
have this yeah all the way all the way
baby all the way who read the IKEA Man
is here so you guys told me that you
find diamonds on level 12 easiest Oh God
cause everything has to be so goddamn
hard you freak you freak you die idiot
first rule of Minecraft then he broke it
just like that so we're gonna dig on
this and then we're gonna gather about a
cobblestone because I papi wants to
build god damn gravel the ruins my life
I hate you gravel oh my god how much
grab a list there god damn gravel okay
that's enough that's enough
bing-bong right there slung here we go
oh my god can spend ride the roller
coaster is that possible maybe we should
try it with someone safer what up my man
you're the main man we're gonna need a
lot of gravel not gravel I hate gravel
gravel ruin my life
a lot of stone you can come with miss
fame no it's getting dark
oh yeah I remember I wanted to build a
stone golem apparently you can build
them yourself and they can protect the
base for you
I need iron blocks all right I have a
lot of iron how do I make an iron block
I run block block of iron is that it
block of iron uno dos tres
I need a t-shape it's a four yeah and
then any a pumpkin but I need to carve
what I do have I do have pumpkins so how
do I carve a pumpkin
maybe I just axe it is this how I do it
spin Oh with the shears oh of course
alright watch this man this is gonna be
epic whoa I remember these these were
actually in the game when I played it
like you can put it on your own face hey
you don't believe it's Wayne I'm a
monster so we put a lantern in it right
don't have any lanterns of course I
don't why would I one two three can't
you see
p-people PPE okay whoa Loki that's kind
of Awesome you're not gonna believe this
I thought people were trolling you make
a t-shape one two three okay I'm a
little short but only in Minecraft wow
that actually worked all right he's
gonna protect us from now on
mr. stone Manny's protection damn that
guy's walking like is nobody business my
rice van alright protect us should we
build more than one while we're at it I
feel like we should got Dan they're
expensive huh not gonna lie I need to
protect my house I have people that I
love that need to be protected
okay alright that's such a weird thing
that you just make them with a pumpkin
another one hello I am your Creator you
should respect me and protect this place
and especially cement don't walk near
there don't walk there you can't that's
right you can't okay we're gonna go to
sleep
sleep time oh right I forgot to show you
guys I have these it was a thunderstorm
and the these guys disappeared with
riders on them and I killed the riders
and then now they're mine you're mine
now
that's right hippity hoppity you try to
kill me you're my property that's how it
works okay actually spend you can come
for this spend it's time to build I I
have actually not built anything on on
minecraft and I wanted to be able
watchtower so let's pick a high spot oh
god it's a tiny little freakish ah you
better not hurt Sven
it's the case of n just stay there oh
god I'm gonna die to this thing huh
jump in the bowl thanks for the helps
man why are they attacking during
daytime I'm built iron golems okay
alright so we build it here this will be
our Watchtower location 1 2 3 PP PP k is
that symmetric no it isn't Thank You
Sven for pointing out boom boom boom one
two three four one two three four
Sven has already latest foundation good
job okay let's keep that pattern going
fails immediately there this is gonna be
late
I've always wanted to build the
watchtower span always okay so this will
be the entrance actually I think I'll
shave these off dude we can have parties
in here spend it could be pretty cool
hey don't try and get up here spend it's
dangerous what did I say what'd I just
say
and now we just like keep building but I
don't want it to be too tall Bing bong
Bing bong Bing bong bong Bing bong see
this is why you guys are missing you say
you don't want me to cut it yeah alright
so now I think it should go in boom okay
I think we have our first floor almost
done spent that's pretty
okay so rule okay that was I should have
probably there we go alright let me make
some letters and I'll be right back ow
Iren you suck what are you yeah guard
the Sheep make sure he doesn't escape
make sure Jeb listen escaped isn't I
right Jeb I would say Jeb
dumb name but I know it's one of the
main developers of this game sir
Jeb is an awesome name ladder any ladder
spend lots of ladders lots of lighters
luckily just weekend Pepe I'm okay
alright doesn't look bad doesn't look
great oh yeah it's okay no ladder
boom boom BAM boom I want you in my room
spend the night together okay so now we
race it from here right
am I crazy or am I just good looking
what boom boom um people maybe we can
have stairs going up and then we'll have
a ladder at the end that'd be cool and
maybe we'll have like a little window
here yah yah yah yah yah yah yah yah yah
window like windows who doesn't like
Windows Apple users only if you're a
Minecraft veteran you know that you can
jump off a high point and place water
right before you hit the ground and you
won't take any fall damage as such and
that's how it's done all right
the watchtower is coming together Sven
what do you think cool all right
he approves maybe we should have like
one more floor and then have some sort
of thing coming out of it yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so one or two floor oh
god Holloway okay I wanted to have
stairs around I think that's cooler
we're gonna make stairs we're gonna make
stairs does that even work can you make
rounded stairs like it will go boom boom
boom boom a peepee poo-poo boom luckily
I had this machine that I stole I mean I
borrowed from the villagers it's pretty
handy not gonna lie it ok so put this
here that looks terrible I know so then
I know sometimes you have to put it down
to realize okay so oh you think this is
an inefficient way of climbing yeah well
your mom is dumb yeah
I'll say it again your mom dumb okay all
right okay all right tell me this is not
a fake cuz it is you can't okay so what
did I say we do one more floor spen get
down from here you're crazy get down get
down down boy down
Jesus Christ this is dog man he's gonna
teleport isn't he hello whoa look at
this dude you sit you sit and wait erase
an absolute mad land
okay Suns going down we best be hurrying
alright time to head back home Sven
oh but he became a rocky let's go back
McKenney walking look at this dude
alright that's good okay so now that I
understand that you need an axe it shot
oh my god yes oh there they are why are
they there your guys suck at least Jeb
hasn't escaped all right I'm gonna form
these and then we're gonna head off to
distant lands and then it's gonna be
epic so I have this other city it's
pretty far away though like really far
away like a montage worthy far away Oh
God
oh my god
here we go this is the city these dumb
traders my god they've been so I've been
swindling them so hard where are they
I'm selling I've been selling their own
crops to them
oh wait I have wheat I put it somewhere
yeah this one is expensive but he'll buy
my pumpkins and melons dude look how
much money I make him do I have to make
melons I forgot you make melon melon in
what word do you make a melon huh
explain that scientists you call
yourself a scientist and then you make
me stop making out not that I'm against
it Oh God Oh God
this one is master level what does that
mean he can make golden carrots okay
lame where did I put all the stuff I got
tired of transporting everything notice
there we go this is the weak man haha
made a great deal there dummy dumb look
at that alright so in this episode we
got a lot of money we got our watch
powers I can't see from here but most
importantly we got the most valuable
thing of all spend if you guys have any
suggestions what else you wanted to see
minecraft let me know and I see you guys
tomorrow
what you never played super simulator
you know it's fun right I'm not supposed
to give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]